quelqu et et ceux qui soutiennent la
cause palestinienne ont une occasion
rêver pourquoi il faut absolument
dissocier la cause palestinienne du
Hamas sinon dans un siècle on se
rappellera que c'est les palestiniens
qui ont découpé des têtes
[Applaudissements]
d'enfants je tiens à te dire mon cher
frère Cyril que on condamne totalement
quelle que soit la barbarie qu'il y a
d'accord les tueries les kidnapping ça
on le condamne fortement ce ne sont
pas 5 millions fr cette confession
musulmane qui qui soutiennent ça en tout
cas moi je vous le dis personnellement
parce que je suis pas un clergé et je
vais parler pour moi
euh ce qu'on est en train de vivre
effectivement est est juste abominable
que on peut soutenir on peut soutenir
bien évidemment les Palestiniens mais
que ce soit absolument pas le Hamas
parce que nous on condamne les gens du
Hamas on peut aussi soutenir Israël sans
forcément adhérer au gouvernement
d'extrême droite de netania euh que
d'ailleurs beaucoup d'amis à moi que
j'ai en Israël sont
totalement totalement contre et qui
veulent la paix les deux peuples veulent
la paix c'est c'est ni le Hamas et ni le
le le l'extrême droite on sait que
l'histoire a donné avec la colonisation
je pense qu'ici on a il y a un certain
sémite ici peut-être que dans nos
familles on a eu des choses graves
durant la guerre en tout cas moi en tout
cas avec la colonisation en tout cas
l'Algérie française d'autres qu'on suit
l'Holocauste j'ai des amis extrêmement
avec qui je suis frère dont certains que
vous avez reçu ici je peux vous en citer
la famille Broman la famille Madar bar
la famille minachem des gens avec qui
j'ai grandi a qui on a fait du sport et
et tout ça j'ai la chance en tout cas de
de d'être là et que tu puisses me donner
la parole contre ça euh euh moi je suis
peiné absolu j'ai reçu effectivement tu
soulignais tout à l'heure les réseaux
sociaux qui se sont totalement oparés de
quelque chose où j'ai reçu moi aussi des
des menaces je dis moi quand je vois sur
les réseaux mort aux Juifs mort aux
Arabes là en ce moment là sur les
réseaux c'est inadmissible je vous le
dis franchement c'est inadmissible on
peut pas voir ça si je pourrais même pas
te dire ce que ce qu'on m'aenvoyait
parce que euh je pense que il y en a qui
choperai une atite ici mais euh nous en
tout cas euh ce que je peux te dire
c'est que euh bah je vis dans le 20e tu
habitais au lilas dans le 20e il y a
deux synagogues euh ces synagogues n'ont
jamais été touché parce que les gens du
quartier dont moi je faisais partie
quand on allait prier le vendredi parce
qu'on avait le même chemin vous priez le
vendredi et nous aussi on prie le
vendredi on connaissait les parents
parce que ces parents-là nous ont gardé
ils nous ont vu grandir ils ont vu nos
parents aussi partir on les a vu partir
et je me refuse
totalement à à dire que aujourd'hui le
le combat c'est musulman à juif mais
bien au contraire c'est un combat qu'on
doit mener tous ensemble
et que lorsqu'on a commencé cette
émission le 4 septembre et qu'on avait
pardonné-moi et je fais le parallèle
avec ça j'en avais parlé à Valérie et à
Géraldine quand on a commencé avec la
baaya et compagnie dis je sais pas si je
vais tenir parce que moi c'est les
choses qui me prennent à cœur et je sais
pas si je suis légitime dans cette
émission à
à à parler de ça donc moi je sais que
dans ma famille il y en a qui ont
beaucoup souffert de la guerre je sais
qu'aujourd'hui il y en a beaucoup qui
souffrent il va y avoir des dommages
collatéraux parce qu'il y a des enfants
qui vont tout perdre des parents qui
vont tout perdre ça commence ça dure
depuis plus de 50 ans qu'est-ce qu'il
faut
faire j'ai pas la solution
personnellement parce que je suis pas un
spécialiste de de ce terrain là on est
là regarder avec les réseaux sociaux et
la télé et
puis la chance que j'ai eu moi en tout
cas dans dans mon enfance d'avoir grandi
avec cette France plurielle je pense à
David Schlomo Philippe
Jean y enfin en tout cas toute cette
France plurielle on on sait jamais parlé
de ça jamais on a jamais parlé de de
guerre bien au contraire tu citais tout
à l'heure que tu voulais pas que ton
fils
euh soit en guerre avec son ami
Edy ben moi en 50 ans on NAA jamais
déraper avec nos frères de France et de
confession juives et
euh j'ai vu une pièce de théâtre
dimanche on débattre ça bon visiblement
c'est un peu
raté
mais je prie de tout cœur en tout cas
pour que un jour il y ait la paix et que
chacun puisse vivre de sa religion de ce
qu'il en soit je voulais juste mettre
une B bémol et ensuite j'arrêterai mon
frère
Cyril dans la rêve partie je pense qu'il
y avait aussi des
Arabes qui étaient là il y a aussi des
arabes qui sont médecins et qui qui qui
bossent en Israël et qui ont peut-être
aussi leur famille à Gaza et qui font
all tour et que parfois le fait que ça
bombarde des deux côtés ben ils vont
plus retrouver leur famille compagnie
alors il faut faire
quoi moi j'ai pas voulu prendre parti
tout de suite sur les réseaux sociaux
parce que j'étais dans un moment de
deuil je savais que ça allait prendre un
élan que moi je ne maîtrise pas que vous
ici vous ne maîtrisez pas parce que nous
moi je ne vis pas à Gaza je ne vis pas
en Israël comme vous mais il y a
effectivement il y a aussi un lien qui
nous rapproche de là-bas soyez de la
famille soit a le côté religieux des
deux voilà ce que je dire je sais pas si
ces technique ce que j'ai dit mais en
tout cas j'ai j'ai j'ai j'ai vu aussi je
parlais avec un pote tout à l'heure et
je lui
disais comment tu veux empêcher des
personnes de confession juives de
défendre Israël et comment tu veux
empêcher des personnes de confession
musulmanes de pas mettre le drapeau
palestinien non mais c'est vrai comment
tu veux faire c'est aujourd'hui
euh j'ai vu des choses sur les réseaux
sociaux je vous dis qui font extrêmement
peur il s'est passé un drame
c'est des
attentats sonans nom qu'on peut pas
nommer qui sont voilà c'est comme le
Bataclan voilà
c'est c'est incroyable ce qui s'est
passé si cétait arrivé en France je vous
dis c'est c'est c'est c'est quelque
chose voilà qui n'est je pense jamais
arrivve en France d'ailleurs part à
l'époque du bataclon où il y a
eueses attentat simultané il faut
d'abord condamner et condamner quoi
qu'il arrive quand il y a des victimes
qui sont des civils qui n'ont rien
demandé quoi qu'il arrive la première
chose à faire c'est condamner c'est ça
et condamné sans mais ou de en même
temps ouais mais de mer je vois beaucoup
de gens là sur les réseaux qui me disent
est-ce que tu vas parler de la France
insoumise bien sûr que je en parler de
la France insoumise c'est normal parce
que la France insoumis a été les
spécialistes du
Mai au départ il y avait même pas de mai
parce qu'au départ France insoumis n'a
pas condamné ces horribles attentats
alors je vois manuel bonpard des membres
de la France insoumis je vais en parler
dans un instant qui s'est rétracté
derrière qui a fait un tweet où il dit
qu'il voulait voulait la paix et au
départ il
a des tweets très compliqué tout comme
on va parler de Louis Boyard mais bon
Louis Boyard dire c'est un
écervelé voilà il a il a plus de
moustache que de cerveau non mais c'est
vrai c'est lui à la limite voilà c'est
un guignol donc on va lui va je sais
même pas si on va parler de lui mais
Emmanuel monpard il dit maintenant il
veut la
paix mon part donc il dit à tout le
monde il faut faire la paix il faut
faire la paix il faut faire la paix bien
sûr faut faire la paix tout le monde
veut la paix ah oui c'est mais déjà il
faut condamner les attentats qui ont été
perpétrés on est d'accord y soit c'est
de la crétinerie connaissent pas
l'histoire et non plus la géographie
soit c'est de l'électoralisme de bas
étage c'est l'un ou l'autre peut-être un
mélange dire manuel bpard il arrive pas
à arrêter de dealer dans les Bouches du
rô il va faire la paix dans le monde
écoutez si on compte après lui non c'est
vrai si on compte sur lui je peux vous
dire on a le temps de voir des drames
encore arriver donc on va en parler dans
un instant et je vais vous reparler je
vous dis de ce qui se passe sur les
réseaux sociaux
et on va se poser les cinq questions euh
sur ce qui s'est passé bien entendu et
je vous le redis parce que je vois
beaucoup de gens là sur Twitter qui ont
pas compris ce qu'on a dit qui disent
ils font l'amalgame entre les les
musulmans et les terroristes bien au
contraire c'est pas du tout ce qu' dit
an au
contraire ex il faut éviter ça parce que
je vous dis
aujourd'hui j'ai eu j'ai eu j'ai eu
plein de potes même du métier qui m'ont
dit euh on est on n pas envie de ça cine
voilà les juif préaniaou aussi il faut
éviter ça on est n'est que de ça c'est
ça on est dans un truc aujourd'hui où il
faut qu'on soit ensemble rassemblé et
euh il y a une entité cancéreuse qui
s'appelle le hamasque qu'empêche tout
mouvement vers la paix depuis maintenant
1987 voilà ce qu'il faut dire
point est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
ce qui se passe avec ce téléphone merci
Michel alors ce téléphone donc avait été
il l'avait perdu en participant aux
recherches il était sur le toit d'une
usine désaffectée le téléphone AA glissé
et serait parti dans un soupirail c'est
ce qu'il avait dit c'est ce qu'il avait
dit oui alors a priori c'est pas
complètement faux il l'avait bien perdu
il était pas vraiment dans un soupirail
puisqu'il était parti dans une gouttière
je vous expliquerai tout à l'heure
comment on l'a retrouvé où je vous
l'explique maintenant maintenant alors
le la date je l'ai c'est le vendredi 29
vendredi 29 septembre à
16h3 trois personnes
arrivent
la maman de Tao et la maman de de Lina
ils ont rendez-vous avec le propriétaire
de cette usine désaffectée qui a été
refabriqué en logement en garage et en
une espèce de d'entrepôt ENF voilà c'est
ça
donc ils étaient venus pour essayer de
récupérer ce téléphone portable je
précise que les gendarmes ne sont pas là
au moment de cette opération bien sûr et
il monte sur le toit il a une ficelle
avec un aimant pour essayer de passer
dans la gouttière afin de remonter
son comme à la pêche he on essaie
toujours quand il est comme quand il est
coincé là entre les deux sièges voilà il
y parvient pas enfin ça devient ça
devient compliqué il y a une femme qui
qui occupe un des bâtiments qui
s'inquiète de voir ce manège cont tenu
du bruit qui a fait la disparition de de
Lina et elle appelle les gendarmes
d'accord les gendarmes arrivent un petit
moment plus tard
euh et là ils vont aider finalement Tao
à récupéré son téléphone qui avait
glissé sous une dalle de béton ils ont
cassé cette partie de de de la dalle ils
ont récupérer le téléphone portable donc
ça c'est une super bonne nouvelle pour
l'enquête c'est qu'on ça ça permettra
peut-être d'ailleurs de de le le mettre
exactement de l'innocenté peut-être
probablement de l'innocenté en tout cas
jusqu'à présent il avait pas menti en
réalité le téléphone à par le soupirail
bon s'il a confondu la gouttière et le
soupirail mais en revanche ils vont
examiner son téléphone les enquêteurs
alors ils vont examiner son téléphone on
va avoir et ça c'est très important
alors je je précise j'ai oublié de le
dire tout à l'heure que je me suis
sérieusement inspiré de l'enquête de ma
consœur six le père du nouveau détective
qui est sur place qui est sur place qui
depuis 3 semaines travaille sur place et
a fait un travail absolument remarquable
donc pour en revenir à ce téléphone
quand il va être analysé par les service
de de gendarmerie
euh normalement on devrait récupérer la
fameuse vidéo qu' que Lina lui aurait
envoyé à 11h20 le jour de sa disparition
le 23 septembre et là les enquêteurs
espèrent récupérer cette vidéo parce que
peut-être que derrière on est à 2
minutes du moment où le téléphone se
coupe c'est ça donc on peut imaginer que
la personne avec laquelle elle est
partie la personne qui l'aurait enlevé
euh est dans le champ euh comme elle
fait un selfie la personne est derrière
à priori enfin on peut l'imaginer il
peut y avoir une voiture également avec
une plaque d'immatriculation qui sera
intéressant de remonter donc ça c'est
quand même un un un espoir que que
fondent les les enquêteurs c'est une
belle avancée dans l'enquête oui avec un
petit bémol c'est que si c'est passé par
snapchat euh ça disparaît aussi vite
enfin dès qu'il a visionné le la vidéo
c'est soit maintenant quelquefois euh
enfin il faut il faut garder l'espoir
bien sûr que
euh que ce film soit que cette vidéo
soit toujours dans son télé pour
l'instant Tao n'a pas menti c'est pour
l'instant Tao n'a pas menti s'il avait
quelque chose àoché est-ce qu'il aurait
pas essayé de de retrouver lui-même son
téléphone ou bien c'est ce qu'il a fait
qu' fait mais en même temps moi je vous
suis pas parce que le téléphone et ça
fait une semaine et demi qu'il l'a perdu
le jour même il a pas dit au gendarmes
je l'ai perdu là venez on le cherche
ensemble le lendemain pourquoi il attend
une semaine et demi pour aller récupérer
tout seul son téléphone cramé par une
nana qui a appelé les gendarmes il
voulait pas le récupérer avec les
gendarmes le téléphone j'ai mal entendu
il s'est bien fait cramer par les
gendarmes magéon s'il te plaît tu te
calmes je
commissaire r mais il VO jour qu'on a
perdu le
téléphone je peux rien répondre à ça si
ce n'est qu'il faut attendre que ce
téléphone soit analysé on verra ce qu'il
y a dedansd CRAM par les gendarmes en
fait il se fait cramer par une voisine
quiz le récupérer tout seul 10 jours
après bé officiellement il nous a dit je
l'ai perdu moi quand j'ai perdu quelque
chose je le retrouve pas l'attitude est
bizarre mais après il a pas varié dans
ce qu'il a dit comme ça non vous c'est
vous lui c'est lui il a il a son mode de
fonctionnement il a menacé un témoin qui
est venu ici et a priori c'est pas
vraiment des menaces enfin c'est sa
façon de s'exprimer reprocher et si
toute la France me dit c'est bizarre tu
as perdu ton téléphone première chose ce
que je fais j'appelle les gendarmes
venez on va le chercher ensemble je vais
vous trou que j'ai rien à me
reprocher
l'éciationéciation ch vous êtes pas ta
plus tu vas avoir peur plus tu vas te
dans la Merde écoutez c'est ça
c'est c'est
c'est c'est l'appréciation de chacun
ouou vot peti enquête si vous voulez
mais pour on a quand même un garçon
du c'est quoi le nouveau détective voilà
donc je vous le dis ça c'est assez
sérieux il y a des nouveaux éléments
dans l'enquête à part ça alors il y a
des nouveaux éléments qui sont plus
moins à mon av moins important que ce
que je viens de de vous dire ça concerne
les temps de breux c'estàd le on sait
maintenant grâce à à à une enquête donc
du nouveau
détective à peu près l'endroit précis
l'endroit exact où elle est prise en
charge par le fameux véhicule c'est donc
c'est quand même une information
importante c'est très important c'est
très important mais je veux dire que ça
fait pas avancer plus que ça mais c'est
ça fait partie des informations que
j'étais venu vous vous raconter donc les
gendarmes poursuivent leur recherche et
ont sondit dans ce on sondait ce ce cet
étant et donc c'est c'est grâce à ça qu'
un certain nombre d'éléments nouveaux
non pas du
[Musique]
toutê s'il vous plaî non attends
excuse-moi le dernier élément
nouveau les enquêteurs
du laissz parleris vous expliquer parce
qu'il y a des caméras de surveillance
aussi pouz pas comprendre j'ai pas
encore raconté l'histoire donc on sait
maintenant où se trouvait Lina au moment
où elle est prise en charge par sans
doute son
kidnappeur grâce au gérant de il y a un
chalet un immense chalet qui fait des
des réceptions or ce samedi 23 au matin
le gérant était là depuis 8h le matin
pour installer l'État pour installer
tout le le le lieu de fête et il connaît
bien Lina et il l'aurait forcément vu
passer or il ne l'a pas vu passer il y a
trois pêcheurs un peu plus loin sur le
fameux étan de breux euh qui eux aussi
connaissent Lina et qui ne l'ont pas vu
passer et enfin troisème élément il y a
une caméra de vidéosurveillance au
niveau de ce chalet c'est important qui
n'a pas filmé alors notre journaliste
elle a a vu elle a fait une photo de de
l'angle de de la caméra ce qu'elle ce
que la caméra voit donc elle a fait la
photo à la place de la caméra et là on
voit le chemin le fameux la piste
cyclable et on sait maintenant que c'est
à cet endroit précis qu'elle a été
enlevée ou qu'elle a en tout cas disparu
c'est ça donc voilà maintenant on sait
pas si voilà on sait que c'est à cet
endroit c'est la dernière trace qu'on a
eu d'elle c'est ici voilà voilà et après
il y a une deuxième info oui c'est quoi
cette nouvelle maison inspectée là alors
la la maison inspectée ça a rien donné
c'est mais quand même pourquoi ils ont
inspecté cette maison euh je n'ai la
maison à poué c'est ça vous parlez la
maison à pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi bah
parce que ils avaient repéré
potentiellement toujours une voiture qui
pouvait correspondre au signalement ils
ont inspecté cette maison la police
scientifique est venue il y avait des
des des enquêteurs avec les blouses
blanches ils ont fait des prélèvements
pour le moment c'est assez proche du
domicile quelques K voà et ça na rien
donné pour le mais ça rien donné c'est
ça mais c'était dans la foulée des de la
du fameux weekend où il y a eu la Clio
où la perquisition de 3 jours vendredi
samedi dimanche a et cilà quels sont les
nouveaux éléments alors le dernier
élément c'est le fameux Robert Dubois
qui est le le témoin clé entre entre
guillemets qui a affirmé avoir vu Lina
passer dans une petite voiture grise ou
bleue il pense que ça peut être une Clio
et elle lui aurait fait coucou ce qui
c'est ça Robert alors notre journaliste
l'a rencontré et on se posait la
question puisqueun moment il cherchait
une Clio bleue que Tao une une Clio
grise on se posait la question de savoir
si éventuellement ce monsieur n'aurait
pas à cause de ses lunettes donc bleu
gris six le père ou enfin est gris clair
la voiture de Tao ou mais bon bon bleu
gris clair et en plus lui alors il y a
deux il y a deux choses soit il se
trompe de jours ce qui est pas
impossible ah merde parce qu'il a 72 ans
même s'il a toute sa tête lui il dit
qu'il regarde pas les infos que ce ce
matinl il s'en souvient bien parce qu'il
avait fait une salade de betterave il
est sorti fumer une
cigarette c'est quel jour il fait les
salades de betterave mais si vous PL non
mais il s'en souvient parce qu'il
souvient sa souvent par rapport à ce
qu'on a mangé qu'on souvient du jour
voilà moi je sais que le vendredi je
mange du poisson voilà alors oui et donc
il sort fumer son petit cigare sur le le
pas de porte et là il voit il voit une
voiture une petite voiture grise ou bleu
passé et il reconnaît Lina dans le
véhicule elle lui fait coucou donc
on on pouvait se poser la question de
ces lunettes donc notre journaliste elle
a rencontré ce monsieur ses lunettes
étaient elle a ESS fait un testologique
elle a essayé ses lunettes pour voir si
ça déformait la couleur complètement
idot bien sûr et en fait je l'ai eu au
téléphone elle me dit que non ça ne
déforme pas le et ça dans le sens opposé
de la gare ça partait vers Strasbourg
dans le S s'opposé de la GAR d' d'accord
d'accord alors ça c'est la l'explication
c'est peut-être qu'elle voulait faire
l'économie d'un d'un billet de train et
que si elle tombe sur quelqu'un qu'elle
connaît qui lui propose de la déposer à
Strasbourg elle a 15 ans eu bien sûr et
elle est pas enfin c'est pas une famille
fortunée bien sûr bon euh au Gille donc
les derniers éléments oui la grosse
interrogation aussi c'est l'état
d'esprit de Lina c'est pour ça aussi je
reviens au téléphone que c'est important
parce que on parle d'une dispute
d'amoureux quelques jours avant on parle
d'une Lina un peu perturbée sa mère au
contraire dit elle était solaire
rayonnante et cetera donc dans le
téléphone on va peut-être pouvoir voir
si les échanges entre Tao et Lina recè
entre guillemets des secrets
voilà compagne il est la star d'M6 c'est
en plus quelqu'un qu'on aime beaucoup
ici on pas voilà on va pas se mentir il
est venu nous voir très souvent Stéphane
et c'est d'ailleurs parce que c'est la
stardem 6 que la chaîne avait programmé
un documentaire à sa gloire ce
soir seulement ce soir il y a
aujourd'hui des personnes et des
collectifs qui sont allés manifester
dans M6 puisqu'il voudrait que ce
documentaire ne soit pas diffusé il y a
de nouvelles informations qui sont
tombées regardez déjà la manifestation
devant
M6 agressur M6 complice Plard agresseur
M6 complice Plard agresseur M6 complice
Plata agresseur M6 complice PLA
agresseur M6 complice PLA agresseur M6
complice il y avait pas il y avait il y
avait quoi il y avait une trentaine de
personnes voilà donc est-ce que 30
personnes comme ça peuvent influencer le
choix d' M6 ou pas du tout ah pas du
tout pas du tout donc le documentaire va
va être diffusé B le documentaire va
être diffusé après une première émission
de de Stéphane Plaza d'ailleurs euh et
ce qui en fait c'est un appel d'Alice
cofin qui fait partie du mouvement
écologiste qui a été fait le il y a 2
jours pour que voilà ces jeunes femmes
et ces jeunes hommes viennent manifester
devant M6 alors euh justement
aujourd'hui ça a un peu rebondi euh sur
Stéphane Plaza qu'est-ce qui se passe
alors une enquête préliminaire a été
ouverte aujourd'hui par le parquet de
Paris en fait deux des jeunes femmes qui
accusaient Stéphane Plaza de violence de
harcèlement et d'agression ont écrit au
à la procureur de Paris et leur
témoignage a été retenu donc une enquête
préliminaire est ouverte aujourd'hui
pour violence contre contre Stéphane
Plazza pour violence conjugale alors
est-ce que ça peut changer quelque chose
Gill Verdez alors à la soirée non mais
on va dire que maintenant bien sûr les
documentaires seront diffusés mais
maintenant l'affaire prend une tournure
judiciaire alors ça ne préjuge
absolument pas de l'issue on est bien
d'accord non seulement il est présumé
innocent mais le terme est même
inapproprié il n'est pas mis en cause
encore mais néanmoins vous savez que
maintenant quand des femmes écrivent à
un procureur il y a eu des consignes
stricts qui ont été passés au parquet on
ouvre des enquêtes et c'est très bien
donc il va y avoir une enquête pour
savoir si ces témoignage pourrait
aboutir à une procédure à l'encontre de
ces justement la question que je pose
aux téléspectateurs euh tant qu'on n'
pas les tenants et les aboutissants de
l'enquête pourquoi M6 devrait
déprogrammer Stéphane Plazza pensez qu'
devrait le déprogrammer ou pas ben moi
je trouve que c'est le fragiliser lui
moi moi personnellement je trouve que
cette soirée elle est malvenu voilà
parce que pour lui c'est compliqué et
pour les plaignantes pour les fanses
c'est compliqué aussi je trouve que le
le recherche appartement maison ça va
mais ce documentaire sur lui sur avec
son père et cetera je trouve que c'est
mal venu ce soir çaurait été mieux pour
moi de diff on pour dire aussi bravo M6
aussi de de soutenir pour l'instant al
ils soutiennent totalement c'est leur
animateur star ils ont une enquête moi
je trouve que ils sont nickel au niveau
de la Procé si l'enquête je pense que si
l'enquête euh mène euh derrière à des
euh Ren si elle mène à rien bah M6 bah
il va continuer à travailler avec Sean
Plazza si elle mène à quelque chose ser
M6 voilà autant qu'ils ont diligenté une
enquête interne aussi M6 donc il y a
rien à dire sur M6 M6 donc là ils font
leur boulot ils disent pour l'instant il
reste à l'antenne il reste à l'antenne
il n'est pas mis en cause officiellement
donc qui pense qui qui qui donc qui est
d'accord avec avec voilà ce collectif
qui penseent que Stéphane pazza devrait
plus être à l'antenne est-ce qu'il y en
a ici autour de la table ou pas du tout
Yan oui moi je pense que c'est quand
même extrêmement douteux de mettre en
cause la parole de femmes qui ont
témoigné alors mettent pas en cause
puisque il la oui mais dans C cas ser
non mais par précaution d'une part et
par respect pour toutes les femmes qui
le soir regardent M6 alors qu'elles ont
pris une raclé par leur mari ou leur
conjoint j'aurais été directeur d' M6
j'aurais évité de programmer un
documentaire comme l'a très bien dit
Gill qui est susceptible de faire de
Stéphan Plaza quelqu'un d'intéressant et
de modèle si c'était une émission lambda
comme il faisait d'habitude il y a pas
de sujet mais une émission à la gloire
de quelqu'un dont des femmes disent et
pourquoi est-ce qu'on ne les croirait
pas qu'il les a frappé sachant qu'il y a
pas pire sur terre que quelqu'un qui
frappe une femme on est bien d'accord
là-dessus c'est de la barbarie ménagère
mais c'est de la barbarie donc mais il y
a une enquête qui a été digentée par M
ça suffit pas pour vous non parce que
parce que d'abord cette enquête interne
on n sait absolument rien c'est facile
de dire je lance une enquête interne
facile on peut en lancer une tous les
jours par précaution et par respect
excusez-moi par respect je pense que le
signal qu'aura envoyé M6 aurait été plus
doux plus intelligent plus respectueux
envers les femmes qui sont aussi des
spectatrices d' M6 plutôt que de
préserver les intérêts de Monsieur
Stéphane Plazza qui passe bien après la
cause d'autant plus que il a été il a
incarné lui la cause des femmes battues
il y a quelques temps il y a un an ou
deux donc tout ça est quand même assez
mal venu et par précaution j'aurais
déprogrammé oui mer non mais surtout là
où le ba c'est que quand même ce ce
documentaire c'est un peu comme comme
vous le disiez un hommage il va c'est un
documentaire émouvant où il va parler
notamment du décès de sa mère ça va
faire pleurer un peu dans les chaumières
et c'est vrai que ça peut paraître un
peu mal venu en ce moment de de de de le
diffuser alors euh oui il y a une
histoire assez similaire et je rejoins
aussi Yan concernant les femmes bien
évidemment que leurs voix sont
extrêmement importantes et qu'il faut
pas les mettre de côté il y a une
histoire avec Gilbert Roson qui était
effectivement juré de de incroyable
incroyable talent et qui avait été
accusé de viol et attentat à la pudeur
et il a été àquité il avait dû quitter
justement l'émission et derrière il a
été rienul non
éid oui mais la raison ils a ils
auraient peut-être pu ils auraient
peut-être pu attendre la fin de
l'enquête aussi pour Gilbert Roson et et
peut-être le voilà l'enlever après c'est
ça l'idée oui moi je trouve que
puisqu'il y a une instruction qui qui
est entamer on verra les conclusions si
si l'instruction démontre qu'il a
effectivement eu des des violences et
ben il va déjà morfler pendant un
certain temps jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
certainement au niveau médiatique là
pour l'instant c'est une période où on
laisse la justice faire son travail et
si M si avait déprogrammé ça aurait été
sous entendu gen on a des infos donc on
se démarque tout de suite doentire le
problème c'est que c'est un documentaire
à sa gloire c'est pas la même chose on
va revenir sur les infos à 20h52
pourquoi une enquête a été ouverte en
fait parce qu'en fait il y a TR il y a
eu trois témoignage je sais pas si vous
en souvenez dans dans miaap part
d'ancienne compagne qui l'a rencontré
notamment sur sur les tournages de ses
émissions dont une qui a amené les
preuves comme quoi elle avait été blessé
au doigt une autre qui apporté des
preuves comme quoi on l'avait menacé
carrément de la tuer il y a eu plusieurs
témoignages qui on é il y a des gens qui
disent je vous le dis qui dit oui mais
si à chaque fois qu'il a un reportage
dans Médi part on on met les gens à
l'écart voilà il est encore innocent à
ce que je sache alors on on change rien
pour l'instant on attendra la fin de
l'enquête voilà les un petit peu je vous
dis un petit peu les réactions mais
entre diffuser l'émission Recherche
appartement ou maison et diffuser
l'intégralité de la soirée sur Stéphane
Plaza il y a quand même une sacrée
différence là il y a re il y a
l'émission très bien elle est tournée
c'est l'émission d' M6 après c'est le
documentaire avec son père qui est
beaucoup plus intimiste où ça peut
effectivement gêner certaines persones
c'est même de la provocation on n' pas
envie de pleurer au aux événements
familiauxx de C fan Plaza si il y a un
doute sur le fait qu'il frappe les
femmes ou pas c'est aussi simple que ça
si c'était son émission habituelle il y
aurait même pas de débat Cyril mais là
on veut nous faire l'armoyer avec un
documentaire à sa gloire alors qu'il y a
des femmes qui
disent question c'est est-ce qu'il y a
une présomption d'innocence médiatique
non il y en a jamais he ça ça il y en a
jamais de présomption pour vous on fait
pas ce documenta non non euh je je dis
simplement qu'effectivement c'est très
violent le tribunal médiatique parce
qu'il n'y a pas de présomption
d'innocence les droits des accusés
médiatiques sont bafoués et c'est pour
ça que c'est très important de dire que
cphan Plaza est présumé innocent ça
simplement comme on veut faire de cette
soirée une sorte de soirée où il est mis
en relief comme le héros d'une soirée et
quelqu'un qui va manifestement nous
montrer ses ses ses fissures ses
faiblesses et que manifestement il va y
avoir des passages émouvants de ce que
j'ai compris on n pas envie d'être ému
par quelqu'un dont on nous dit en ce
moment qu'il frappe les femmes jeés il
est présumé coupable je
dis moi je vais vous dire chacun et vous
allez dire il dit une phrase bateau mais
je dis moi chacun voit m à sa porte il
faut arrêter un moment s'il y a des
artistes qui veulent réagir ils le font
moi j'ai réagi pourquoi si je vous dire
j'ai une émission en direct tous les
jours j'ai vu he sur les réseaux tout le
monde a dit pourquoi sir pourquoi sir je
réagis pas moi je vous dire j'avais pas
envie juste de faire un post ou ou de
faire un tweet voilà qui serait voilà
j'aurais pas pu m'exprimer pleinement
comme je l'ai fait dans cette émission
donc forcément moi j'étais et je le dis
j'ai aucun mérite moi j'étais obligé de
réagir j'ai une émission en direct tous
les jours je parle d'actualité si je
réagis pas on va dire ce mec là il est
fou Hanouna c'est un guignol voilà donc
forcément je suis obligé de réagir après
kyian Mbappé je suis désolé les gars moi
je vous dis la vérité Kilian Mbappé les
autres artistes moi c'est des mecs il
vont
dire nous au fO
COM pr la Paro pour tout et
norteo parce que les gars
laoglycérine dis
les gar je me fais l'avocat du diable
j'ai parlé à plein de monde tous les
gars ils me disent comment je fais C
qu'est-ce que je fais qu'est-ce que
je il y a une telle haine sur les
réseaux sociaux qui disent si je mets un
truc je vais me faire défoncer idée
alors j'ai une idée j'ai réfléchi à cela
j'ai vidé j'ai fait une vidéo je
demandais justement mais vous êtes où
vous êtes où ils sont où j'ai une idée
pour c'est très simple l'idée on demande
pas de prendre parti on le demande pas
de dire vive Israël on leur demande
juste de dire quelle que soit votre
opinion
nous sommes tous contre le pas dire que
cette phrase ils sont pas capables de la
dire qui touche les Français parce qu'il
a français qui sont morts et 18 qui sont
toujoursorté on sa pas s sont en otage
ou s sont donc ça concerne où il
vraiment quel chose je vous dire les
mecs c'est vrai qu'on leur demande pas
grandchose c'est juste dire non mais
après moi je parle des mecs qui
réagissent à tout je suis assez d'accord
des mecs qui réagissent à tout qui
réagiss pas vu Mo déjà réagi sur plein
de choses Mar déjà ré après je dis leur
nom mais peu importe c'est pas eux
précisément maisux qui d'habitude
prennent parti et sont de tous les
combats pourquoi pas celuilà qu'est-ce
qu'il a dans celuil quce ch là c'est pas
un combat pour dire je suis
pro on leur demande juste de dire ce que
vous voulez dire on
condam
est qui soutienent la cause
palestinienne on une occasion rêver
pourquoi il faut absolument dissocier la
cause palestinenne du Hamas sinon dans
un siècle on se rappellera que c'est les
palestiniens qui ont découpé des têtes
d'enfants alors que c'est le Hamas qui a
pris en otage le peuple palestinien
depuis des années donc vous voyez bien
que soutenir la cause et être contre le
terrorisme et mieux que la France
indigne et dire oui on combat contre le
terrorisme d'abord ça permet à
l'Autorité palestinienne de rebondir
mais deuxièmement on parle aux jeunes et
aux jeunes de quartier qui ont été
complètement mais manipulés par les
idées de la France indigne on le sait
très bien et qui essaent d'importer ce
conflit depuis des années parce que je
peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui il est le
temps justement on en parlait de la
violence pour calmer le jeu comme eux
ces stars là ont l'oreille déjà jeun ils
ont non pas le droit mais le devoir de
le faire parce qu'ils ont une
responsabilité ils ont l'oreille des
jeunes et en disant cal mon jeu on est
tous unis contre le terrorisme on
évitera la violence dans notre
pays ex exceptionnel me c'est un
mec VI il est exceptionnel c'est vrai
que je suis d'accord je suis un peu
d'accord avec vous là-dessus c'est vrai
qu'il y a des mecs ils sont à gométrie
variable ils ont des sensibilités la
géométrie variable voilà et ils
choisissent un petit peu le cause mais
les mecs ils se disent je vais dire
est-ce que ils ont peur de de plus être
aimé par une partie du public est-ce
qu'ils ont
peur plus rentr les estce on peur s'il
vous plaît oh de ne plus amener des gens
au cinéma est-ce qu'ils ont peur de ça
est-ce que aujourd'hui le truc qui est
grave c'est ça qui est grave c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des artistes en
disant non au terrorisme ils font défon
ils ont peur derrière de se faire
défoncer sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
c'est incroyable et ça on a la vidéo de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon dans un instant vous
allez voir sur Enrico Matas mais ça
c'est incroyable ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui tu tu peux pas dire tu es
contre le terrorisme mais c'est ça le
terrorisme ils font peur si on a peur
même de condamner le terrorisme ils ont
déjà gagné faut savoir ce qu'on veut
comme société est-ce qu'on laisse aux
terroristes le fait de nous terroriser
mentalement ou est-ce qu'on décide de
résister et la vraie résistance c'est la
lutte contre le terrorisme le Hamas n'a
jamais éé un mouvement résistant arrêter
de croire les réseaux sociaux d'ailleurs
ce matin jeis pas vous avez vu mais la
page wikipédia du Hamas a été modifiée
avant il y avait marqué mouvement
terroriste et depuis ce matin il y a
marqué mouvement de résistance islamiste
depuis ce matin vérifierors j'ai la
photo Jean-Michel tu voulais ragir oui
oui parce que je trouve on a pas 36000
occasion de d'être un homme dans sa vie
donc quand dans les moments difficiles
comme ça c'est comme ça qu'on bah qu'on
prend position qu'on prend des positions
courageuses même si on peut craindre des
réactions d'un côté un autre parce que
quand la guerre se déclare là pour
l'instant c'est une une guerre qui est
régionale qui pourrait s'étendre on sait
jamais on a jamais cru avant chaque
guerre j'avais déjà dit une fois
quelques jours avant déclenchement du
guerre mondiale on savait pas que la
guerre arrivé voilà si le conflit devait
par malheur progressivement se se
s'étendre et ben un moment dans la ligne
de front il y a qu'un il y a que deux
côtés hein on est d'un côté ou d'un
autre il y a plus de oui mais et cetera
non on est d'un côté d'un autre donc à
un moment faut se moi je suis pour que
les gens et ben ils prennent position
voilà après ça tire les foudes de
l'autre partie mais faut moment faut
savoir qui est pour qui et qui est pour
qui est a les artistes qui on pas
réagiah en tout cas moi j'aimerais bien
qu'il se qu' se non mais là bah oui
j'aimerais bien qu'il y en ait plus qui
se qui se franchement c'est pas
trèsant c'est quoi c'est pas très
apaisant ce que tu dis dire de devoir
choisir un côté ou l'autre des personnes
pr informé personnes qui ne SAV le
terrorisme tu sais ce que c'est quand
même bien
s quand il dit faut choisir un camp ou
l'autre tu V attend savoir qui va gagner
pour choisir tonamp pas attendez sil
vous PL s'il vous plaît on parle moment
on est un pays faut arrêter de nous tout
le temps nous diviser là moment se
rassembler contre le terrorisme mais
après ce que tu dis c'est choisir un
camp ou l'autre attendez Guillaum
Guillaume les personnalités
doivent-elles réagir à ce qui s'est
passé non parce que toutes les
personnalités qui se sont positionné on
vient de le voir avec Enrico mas se
retrouve dans une sauce pas possible moi
je me suis positionné non vous avez
réagi vous avez condamné le terrorisme
évidemment qu'il faut condamner le
terrorisme je
par y a des personnalités qui ont mis
des drapeaux d'Israël ou de la Palestine
qui se sont retrouvés menacés qui ont
question c'est c'est juste
réagir dit le terrorisme c'est
horrible
problème moi je pense que pourquoi les
artistes doivent pas réagir vous parce
que vous l' vous avez prononcé le mot
c'est de la nitroglycérine pour eux les
artistes extrêmement fédérateur ben non
mais je vous dis pourquoi à mon avis il
réagissent
pas non non pas du tout c'est c'est des
très grands des très grandes star Mbappé
au marc alors ils vont peut-être réagir
attention mais en fait fa il sont tell
féérurs ils ont un public qui est d'un
bord à l'autre ne veulent pas prendre le
risque par qu'il que pour eux ça
pourrait être ou une fin de carrière ou
se privé de mais je vous dis pas qu' on
raisonexlique ce qu'il pour les joueurs
du PSG c'est extrêm
compliqu fédérateur Mo je l'ai regardé
lundi je suis désolé son discours il
était pas du tout il ne divisait
personne donc c'est possible en tant que
que que
VO en encore une fois Gill on leur
demande pas de dire je suis pour le
gouvernement d'Israël ou je suis pro
israélien et cetera on leur demande pas
ça on leur dit juste vous dites que je
condamne le terrorisme c'est tout si
vous avez raison pourquoi ne le font-ils
pas si vous avez raison pourquoi ne le
font-il pas parce qu'ils ont peurs ont
peur par ont peur ils ont peur il faut
le dire vous avz dit nitroglycérine ils
ont pe je aller plus loin vous ils ont
pas peur ils ont peur de défendre des
victimes juives israélien je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi
l'affaire Sarah liimi bien sûr que des
Juifs j'ai organisé avec Jonathan Béard
la réunion entre cadero que des Juifs à
5 % il a limi que des Juifs Ozar à
trouvez-moi les photos de manifestation
en France alors que c'est peut-être une
des actions les plus épouvantables qu'on
a jamais sur le sol français dès qu'il
s'agit de victime juive et ou alors
israélienne c'est pire encore parce que
quand on Israël ça veut dire ça veut
dire qu'il y a un traitement différent
des victimes c'est ça la honte
c'est toutes les vitimes son traité de
la même façon restons sur les
personnalités Delphin est-ce qu'on peut
pas se dire que toutes les les
personnalités qui ne qui ne réagissent
pas là-dessus on va pas tous dire qu'
qu'elles sont pour le terrorisme
justement bien sûr chaque être humain
est contre le terrorisme c'est une
vérité générale donc en fait il y a pas
à le dire à part les monstres personne
n'est pour le terrorisme mélchon alors
vous part les monstres en revanche en
revanche pour l'autre sujet pour l'autre
sujet les gens ne s'expriment pas quand
ils ne savent pas et je trouve que c'est
l'intelligence
faire rien dire
d'
auourditb
TER sur trblement TER au Maroc
normal franais
cuse on va pas trouver un seul Français
qui est pour le
terrorismeoè pas il paspport dans le
monde de
excusemoi le monde est cont le terroris
on fait rien mais bon mond mie rien dire
comme ça il y a un fait horrible de
terrorisme du coup c'est bien parission
de ne rien dire ça veut dire
tu peux pas dire ça ce sont des gens qui
parlent au banlieu demande un petit
gamin sil Rê pas devant kan Mbappé je
dire non ces gensl ont un devoir ils ont
un devoir d'exemplarité on leur demande
pas du tout de faire de politique
surtout pas moi un conseil en
communication sur un événement comme ça
je leur dis tu tu réagis dans les 24
heures tu as besoin de faire deux mots
il y a des community managers qui savent
faire ça très bien je suis pour la paix
c'est horrible je sais pas des phrases
très terrorisme juste pour dire un truc
par je exprimé tout à l'heure sur sur la
question de de Mélanchon et de la France
insoumise c'est quand même un parti
Cyril qui nous a aussi dit qu'il n'était
pas tout à fait Charli donc on ne peut
pas mettre les choses l'unes en face des
autres on peut pas créer une polémique
autour de Enrico Matias qui est le seul
artiste alors je parle pas des hommes de
télévision comme toi puisque tu l'as
fait dès lundi matin mais c'est le seul
artiste à avoir eu le courage cet homme
de paix de dire mais enfin mais c'est
pas possible je suis pour la paix et
aujourd'hui on crée c'est une obè
formidable pour la France insoumise de
pouvoir ouvrir une nouvelle sé de
communication qui consiste à dire voilà
notre a nous nous sommes victimes c'est
un
Scand je suis choqué parce que j'aime
Karim ou et je le connais depuis plus de
20 ans on a fait des dizaines de
plateaux ensemble et et sa VZ que j'ai
eu un problème hier quand j'ai écouté
Karim mon ami parce qu'en fait je Tai
pas reconnu et je me suis dit mais où
est le Karim que j'aime où est le Karim
avec sa compassion pour toutes les
causes où est le Karim avec son
intelligence sa sensibilité et sa grand
grande gueule pour dénoncer justement
toutes forme de terrorisme de fascisme
et cetera ou est aussi le Karim avec son
humanité immense qui est passé à côté de
la dénonciation de l'acte terroriste où
est le Karim qui va s'intéresser au sort
des victimes quel qu'elle soit et là je
me suis dit finalement où es-tu mon ami
ce Karim que tu connais depuis 20 ans
qui n'a pas changé et qui ne changera
pas parce qu'il a des convictions
chevill au corps il a déclaré en Algérie
dans la press algérienne mais c'est pas
le passage qu'on a préféré passer je
voudrais tout d'abord dire ma peine
concernant la perte des populations
civiles palestinienne et israélienne
lorsqu'un enfant une femme ou une
personneagée meurt suite à des actes de
violence et de barbarie c'est une
émotion intense que je ne peux
m'empêcher de ressentir et ce sans
distinction d'origine de nationalité ou
d'appartement d'appartenance religieuse
s'agissant des victimes notre monde se
déshumanise complètement avec la S de la
classe politique à l'échelle planétaire
et c'est très inquiétant on a parfois
l'impression d'être dans une compétition
de l'horreur alors que le drame et la
douleur touchent des populations civiles
je ne mélange pas les actes de barbarie
écoute ça c'est très important oui sur
des femmes et des hommes des actes de
barbarie sur des femmes et des hommes à
la cause légitime du peuple palestinien
qui est humilié et qui souffre depuis 75
ans alors mon ami l'ami que tu as depuis
20 ans il dit ça et il dit la suite mais
l'ami que tu as depuis 20 ans il est
triplement scandalisé aujourd'hui par la
manière dont on appréhend de ce qui se
passe en Israël en
Palestine d'abord d'abord le premier
scandale de mon point de vue c'est de ne
pas condamner clairement la barbarie qui
a touché des civils israéliens vous
pensez quoi tu l'as pas fait tu l'as pas
fait excuseo'est je vi qu'est-ce que je
viens de dire là mais tu alors tu vas le
relire je crois que tout le monde a
entendu tu le dis non excuse-moi Karim
comme tu es mon ami je peux aussi te
dire dire tu n'as pas clairement dit dès
le début tu as parlé d'abord il y a pas
d'ordre victime palestinen israélienne
tu pu le faire dans l'autre sens je ne
t'ai pas entendu une fois par je ne l'ai
pas entendu une fois dire je condamne
l'attentat du Hamas sur la population
israélienne vrai ou pas juste d'abord tu
n'es ni un juge ni un procureur je ne
suis pas là dans un
tribunal je te dis mon ami pourquoi tu
t'énerves si tu veux si tu veux qu'on
discute et qu'on
débat t've pas mais comme je suis ton
ami on sécoute quand on était côte à
côte au GG on s'écoutait là tu m'écoutes
pas pour s'écouter il faut être
deuxas pour faire la paix comme pour
faire la GU tu insinu des choses me
concernant je viens de te lire un
passage c'est écrit tu sais on dit les
paroles s'volent mais les écrits restent
c'est écrit c'est à ta disposition tu
condamnes pas le l'acte terroriste tu
n'as pas dit que le Hamas était un
mouvement terroriste il faut dire que tu
condamnes de façon absolument
absolu
question le H c'est un
mouvement par s'il vous plaît c'est trop
facile c'est trop simple
l'instrumentalisation l'interprétation
la déformation c'est le drame de ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui dans not société fr
quelqu'un s'exprime et on déforme on
interprète et on veut lui faire dire ce
qu'il n'a pas dit moi je suis très clair
que ce soit sur C news sur une radio
algérienne et sur un journal le même
hier soir j'étais sur C news le même et
je vais te dire ce qui me scandalise
triplement d'abord c'est que il n'y ait
pas eu de dénonciation de condamnation
des actes commis à l'encontre des civils
israéliens cette barbarie tout le monde
ne l'a pas condamné j'ai été choqué j'ai
été choqué que l'arost disproportionné
qui voit aujourd'hui des milliers de
morts
260000 palestinien déplacés de Gaza
n'est pas par d'autres personnes été
condamné de la même manière en fait j'ai
l'impression que il faut choisir son
camp je suis désolé mais on peut avoir
une une cause une sensibilité mais
pensez qu'un enfant qui meurt qui soit
palestinen ou israélien la peine est la
même la souffrance est la même est-il
possible aujourd'hui d'avoir un débat
serein sans jeter des anathèmes aux uns
et aux autres en jetant le propre et le
doute il y a des ennemi de la paix c'est
à cela qu'il faut aujourd'hui s'adresser
de part et d'autre ne te trompe pas de
cible tu es en train de faire une erreur
parce que tu épies chaque mot et tu
lèves ceux qui ne te conviennent pas
pour ne pas retenir ce qui pourrait te
convenir
tu vexer tu vas t'exer Mo on m'a promis
on m'a dit tu pourras dire compqué ce
que tu pensesè scandale le deè parce que
le premier le premier le premier c'est
de ne pas MRE un mort palestinien au
même niveau comme israélien c'est pas
rigolo parce que c'est grave de pas
faire parce que là on est en train de
parler de de perte
civile c'est de balayer de revers demain
les causes qui nous amèent à cette
situation ça fait 56
ans merci Karim alors attends parce
que on m'avait pas dit que tu me coup 20
secondes j'ai parlé j'ai parl 20
qu'est-ce qui peut justifier
l'injustifiable rien rien peut justifier
le batlan rien justifie ce qui s'est
passé samedi désolé Karim mais tu bien
que ton
discoursours discoursme les
prop pas pas de propos qu les gens
écouter ce que tu as dit à Radio
ALG attention c'est enreistre c'est en
direct c'est en direct les gens sur
Radio ALG tu dis
rienam ni ni terroriste tu parles de
rien radio ALG je vous encourage à
l'écouter a un propos cé question
poser est une responsabilité politique
de l'État d'Israël à la situation
aujourd'hui du peuple palestinien qui
n'a pas d'état je te rappelle je une
question je
répondre
tergiverséivers allezy répondez qui gère
la bande de Gaza depuis 2005 question le
Gaza Gaza pardon à Gaza qui est parti
d'ailleurs de façon unilatérale du jour
au lendemainon en disant maintenant vous
gérez
çaonsabilité la différence entre toi et
moi c'est que moi je suis ri je suis
écout
bien automatiquement une responsabilité
politique on l'a dit hier je le dis tout
le temps pourquoi que Hamas est une cré
je mais tu te rends compte ce que tu
dis is disent des
diplomates rel que la parole de qui de
l'Intérieur ont expliqué sa stratégie
est-ce que c'est une stratégie à
laquelle tu crois ou pas écoute non
seulement j'ai honte pour toi mais je
dire ça correspond à un chef du Hamas
hier qui expliquait qu'il y avait pas de
victime civil et que donc évidemment que
quand il découpa en morceau qu'il tuait
habitants il est considéré comme des
Ren sit écoutemoi mais tu n'écoutes pas
tu fais que si on faisait un décomte
comme aux échecs tu serais à 100% du
temp laisse-moi un petit peu sais N et C
ten fais pas il y a pas besoin de moi ni
de personne pour le critiquer en Israël
tous les jours et toi tu n pas tu pas
alors moi j'y suis tous les jours
laisse-moiir monolog so pe par tous les
jours on le critique du matin au soir on
n pas besoin de personne pour critiquer
la politique israélienne est critiqu en
Isra plusque ailleurs parce que au moins
ils connaissent ce
[Applaudissements]
pays